all right
uh hopefully this is all working hello
everyone
a couple minutes early or late depending
on which platform you're watching on but
today we're gonna play the barbarian we
played the amazon and the sorceress
yesterday my name is eric turns out
the whole time i thought i was talking
yesterday uh it wasn't actually getting
sent out to the streams hopefully today
it is
i'm gonna try to fact check that with
chat in just a second
and so let's make the barb
[Applause]
and we'll get on our way
don't know louis when the uh good day
beta is going to drop
unfortunately or when the next alpha
even is going to
be uh sound is fine awesome
okay we're gonna go see how far we can
get in
um you know the limited time
[Music]
we hear you thank you oh i got you
baited
the exits the other way every time i
played yesterday it was uh
on the top part of the map great start
so i'm probably jinxing it now didn't
die once yesterday hopefully not dying
today
beware foul demons i'll also be honest
though
i didn't really play barb that much when
i played diablo like back in the day
uh so
we'll see how it goes oh
wow ring off the bat that's pretty good
it's not going to help us that much but
we'll take it you can always sell the
ring it'll be worth more than the uh
80 or so that we went on
[Music]
uh limited time meaning i have like an
hour and a half to two hours to play
probably
and also there's only two acts in the
game right now so
i didn't highly doubt we're gonna get
the very own beat durian in the uh
first up to two hours here but i'll do
my best
see how we get along
trying to find the den of evil i should
just follow the paths here i'm chopping
zombies and all that stuff sound lower
please which one
kills your gameplay or
the music okay i guess we could do it in
game
and then see if that how that works out
for everyone
[Music]
there are many foes here this is a game
we'll be like crack edition for first
console players yup
for sure i think so i played the crap
out of this game
and it looked like this and i'm
so excited one to be able to be playing
in this alpha
and uh two just to kind of have it
brought back to life
you know in the uh the current state of
things
can't wait to like i know the switch
isn't the most um
visually stunning platform but just
having d2
on the go is that's insane right like
being able to play d2 on your couch
um i'm really looking forward to that
i should probably
i'll probably get a little bit of decks
uh even though that sounds weird just to
make sure we
can hit what we're trying to hit also
realizing
there's some guys back there wow we're
just
drop rates seem kind of loaded huh
we have two large charms already
not your cup of tea that's okay like not
every genre or every game has to be
liked by everyone good to have
you know a bunch of games that different
people can enjoy
play and talk about all that stuff
either way glad you're here to to hang
out
on our barb run in the technical alpha
maybe we just go do a wheel with the
club
it's a club more damage
i feel like barb is kind of slower to
start compared to like
everything else real quickly
i can't use this yet oh really a little
sick so
my bad we will eventually put these
culminating visual style looks really
good yeah we'll we'll do some
like if you haven't seen it we did a
comparison on gamespot uh
check it out on youtube the other thing
is i can just easily kind of like toggle
back and forth you guys to see some of
the differences
so i'm sure we'll we'll check some of
those out
um maybe when there's more stuff going
on
so you guys can see it
i should probably level i haven't
leveled at all
for anyone that's returning from
yesterday's stream i didn't wear boots
for the longest time
chad got bad boots today
a little i'm gonna put one two three
four
five one
also i don't know if anyone was here
from yesterday but um
i did not mean to drop 80 points of
strength into my sorceress going into
respect that basically almost got us
killed
by imperial but we made it work out
that's what matters uh if you're new to
the stream and you haven't
uh kind of seen what we did yesterday
there are some nice quality of life
things uh
auto pickup on gold is great
oh this guy is gonna not want to fight
[Music]
i think my buddy got a legendary off of
uh
definitely id the axe we might go maces
though because i think
like scepter damage is pretty hard to
beat in the beginning of the game
oh he didn't level till act two that's
insane
i mean it's doable but it's definitely
not ideal right
there's one monster i bet he's down in
this little nook here
is he nope uh oh this is
this is a problem
where did we not oh you can also see
that they move the map location
oh do they actually no that's an
entrance right
oh this is gonna be fun finding that one
last denim
evil monster uh you hope that the
inventory gets updated i don't think
they'll do it i feel like it's part
like inventory tetris is part of diablo
2 and even like
the whole like you know because charms
take up slots
in your inventory you kind of have to
manage that too so i don't foresee them
changing that
i mean maybe but how is he at the front
so here you can kind of see like this is
what it looks like when you clear it
this is kind of like what it looks like
back in the day we'll go back to a car
later she'll give us a ring but i think
we're gonna make
our way to
the next area and then get the waypoint
and then
we'll kind of go back to town
oh you know what we should do we should
probably
i think just ready as an alpha got all
hype quickness yeah sorry i try to be
somewhat transparent in titles so that
they don't get too
wonky um but it feels pretty good and i
don't
outside of one little kind of blip
yesterday where i had some
performance issues which could have been
on my end totally uh
and we had one crash yesterday but other
than that it's been great
i've played through all of act 2 with my
swork
and i got to near the end of act one uh
pre and dario on my amazon
so should be good
wow so this is why you i guess you level
some dexterity
and if you see me buy stamina pots it's
so that we don't get stuck
walking it's really annoying
there's flavi so we should be close to
the
exit
even the animations on like kill they're
like so much better
cap ethereal is probably going to break
oh that was a weird one of course as i
tell you guys
we didn't have any problems there we get
a little uh yeah we're on pc
yeah this is what happens this is what
the inventory looks like
and then if we go back to this a little
bit bigger
i am a car you have
oh this is big money right here well
considering how poor we are that would
have been pretty nice
to have yesterday two chart three charge
bolt two warrant five
life this would have been insane on my
sorceress yesterday to start
uh we got enough to buy some tow so do
it
poor man is kind of whatever we'll take
the five attack rating i guess we'll
just
yeah sure whatever we're gonna buy some
stamina pots and then probably
oh we can try to see it let's see
uh can we afford that we can't really
right
we'll take these we'll take these two
scepters right now
[Music]
sell that axe sell that axe
i think we're gonna go maces
we don't need all the pally abilities
though so
looking at the tree we're gonna go maces
eventually we're gonna get like double
swing but that's at level six so we'll
probably just
bash it just base it up just
manual attack it check for some hate
recovery stuff and then
no announcement date yet sean richards
on um
when the game will come out but uh
let's see what she's got um when the
strength
12 attack rating definitely want a belt
right
sure sure
and i think with that we're good right
oh i didn't buy salmon apostles
actually don't even need all those mana
pots right now
but yeah inventory management's a thing
so let's just buy some stampin up bots
and then
hopefully you get in on the next one
really thanks for stopping by though and
hanging out
we'll probably go kill a blood raven
just for the lulls
are we just playing classic uh
on the remaster no i mean
there's a bunch of quality of life stuff
there's shared stash
i haven't tried it yet but i'd imagine
it works rear
quilted arm
we'll see if we end up with blood
raising but i'll fight here
[Music]
receptors are doing work
[Applause]
vitality
lmlo
why not stamina pods are great i don't
know
about you i like them
i think they're great especially when
you get stuck with no stamina and then
you have to walk
no thanks i'll buy stamina all day
if you want to take a casual
but hey i'm not going to tell you how to
play it you do you
let's see where nope this is probably
stoney fields
do you guys want to see bloodraven do
you want me to go look for her
uh you can also see like just like the
movement like it's it's
way smoother and like here like
just watch this for a while right and
then
and look at just the scepters too just
the uh difference
quality of the character the quality of
the weapon
go kill blood ready written on player
eights
for the lulls yeah i can't i can't do
multiplayer in this one sadly
whoa we were strolling up on that rock i
guess
this is why we have stamper pots because
i don't want to be stuck like that
not gonna play like in that uh old mode
as much
will this have land or offline
so that's the weird one right there's
definitely single player
right because i created my character and
i can show you the main menu earlier
but originally at least for the tech
alpha and i don't know if this is gonna
[Music]
the full release but uh
i had to be connected to the launcher
which then makes me think i have to be
online
so hopefully not online only because
then
yeah because i mean even diablo 3 on
switch if you want to play solo
uh who is that wiggly six ain't nobody
focuses on good gameplay anymore they
just focus on practice i don't think
that's true i think there's been a good
uh quite a bit quite a few games with
um great gameplay
not just graphics i think the reason why
something like this is appealing
for someone like me is because you know
i played this game so long ago
still played it to some degree even now
and
having a hd version great
i'll take it i'm holding the button like
i'm probably not i'm probably part of
the problem in your mind because i'm
willing to buy like two copies
you know pc two socket helm is great um
i wanted to buy like pc
version and switch version
[Music]
pull damage
we're gonna die dude
i can do it barbaric
that's kind of what it looks like
[Music]
hopefully this is better can you do zoom
in yes
here you go
found that out yesterday
f is uh for zooming
very curious
not great might sell the ring we'll see
no abilities um
i have them all into maze mastery right
now i'm looking to get double swing
uh what level are we right now we are
level four
so two more points
so in theory i could put one more mace
mastery i think i'll take the gas
let's do that real quick
all right so we got mace mastery and
then the next two points we'll put into
bash
and double swing
i should have hit up that uh i should
have hit up the
uh well just now oh hold on sorry i need
to lower this so i can see chad
you can opt out of gore mode uh
i don't know i have to take a look at
the options i've never thought about
that
i guess i guess there is blood splatter
on the ground so we'll get bash now
so that we can get
i'm gonna put it in i know it seems
weird to put it in decks
i want to make sure we will add the
attacks probably get to
35 decks and then we'll start
probably dumping into vitality
uh i guess we can see what batch looks
like
yup it's got that classic sound
i mean i'm still missing with that much
decks
yeah sekiro is a good example thank you
brian um
trying to think what else i feel like
personally i
enjoy apex legends quite a bit i think
the movement the
and the shooting in that game is like
really good and that's
not necessarily a game that has like
crazy visuals right
oh there's a wand you need to pick that
up for the money potentially
yeah it's got some stats on it or some
uh
skills which will equate to money
we'll take the stamina so now we're
looking for
like wrecking issue and the stones
before we head up to
the forest
is that the okay so we found the
underground passage we gotta find the
the stones which is
crazy that we didn't run into it
all right
for those that oh there's a waypoint
very good the points are always good
i guess we could always just go to the
dark wood
and head on over before finding these
stones
since we do have the waypoint back now
but um
up there the stones i guess we'll kill
rock and issue or try to hopefully magic
stones are ancient
oh we bashed him in one shot okay we'll
take that
uh we'll come back to the stones
all right so now we're gonna go to the
underground passage we'll go get the
scroll
until we get the scroll we'll save
deckard
and then we'll um head on over
to the counts
the countess try to get some ruins
don't know if we'll farm for like was it
steel tur
l but we could i don't i don't think
i don't think uh stealth really affects
bar but we could
try to farm tile for those of you who
know ruin words
so star from star wars battlefront 2
failed killing joke comic isn't the same
uh have you played battlefront 2 though
since it's gone like free and like they
kind of went away from the kind of
predatorial
micro transaction stuff because i
actually had quite a well maybe it's
because it was free for me but like i
did have a lot of fun
playing battlefront um on epic games
when it kind of uh got re-released
or was free and i enjoyed it quite a bit
with my
my friends um when it did come out
so that's just a personal take if you
didn't enjoy
battlefront um and i can understand why
maybe two in the beginning
that's that's fair but i think it did
get better
is controller support available yet i
think if i read the
uh if i read the
post right the blog post about the
technical alpha i think they said it's
in there
it's in here but it's not like fully
like
fleshed out i don't think um i could try
plugging in an xbox
controller like xbox uh like
one xbox series x controller in and
trying it if people are interested
in the controller support i would
imagine it's pretty easy
until like you have a lot of skills but
i think even then it's not like you're
mapping a lot of hotkeys
so if you're just cycling between skills
i'm sure there's a way to do that
right and most people i would say
once you kind of get your final build
down the road you're not really
switching between too many skills right
i can't care
i definitely want that scepter
we have so many mana pods
scepter
yeah yes try that okay can um
let me see i gotta find okay there's my
xbox controller
and let me find the cable okay some
all right i'll do that in a second okay
um
i will try plugging it in and giving it
a go in one second
i've i've played diablo 3 on ps4 and
that was
totally fine with me and i played diablo
3 on the switch
both were pretty good in my
opinion and you got to imagine too like
if you guys have played path of exile
guys and gals have played path of exile
and it works on console
there's no reason that um d2 wouldn't
work on console then right because
there's even
i'd imagine less abilities than
something like a poe
would have i'm going to go back up top
in case it's up here
oh we want attack rating uh
i think i'll take the decks
extra life has noted that controllers
work and it's well intelligent oh sweet
was it cass um i know he was streaming
yesterday
a lot of the content creators i had it
earlier myself included
luckily thank you to blizzard and
um my fortunate ability to
work at gamespot to be able to play the
game really
but yeah we can definitely give it a go
and it's good to hear that the
controller works so
maybe we'll do that once i get the uh
once i get back into town i'll switch it
over
i have played path of exile it's kind of
the same thing as diablo has a lot of
similarities yeah and um for those who
didn't see it yesterday
we found the tree really fast by the way
uh the
path of exile stuff looked really good
yesterday path of exile too
man my barb is just getting the luck
today huh
compared to yesterday's drops um oh crap
we need
we need the space i might sell and then
come back
because i think it's worth kind of
getting rid of some of this stuff good
welcome all right we got a follower it's
fine
yeah path of xl2 looks good they even uh
the funny thing is they even have like
javazon abilities
which i think is funny that was worth it
i guess
10 life uh we'll take that more than the
mana
no we can't use it yet but that's fine
dang where was this yesterday oh it's
got 51 attack rating though
so that's that's good uh 10 10 fcr
though is so good uh this early for
a whiz resorcers
stamina
okay oh yeah controller support right so
let's
try that real quick um sorry if you guys
hear like a
like a ping for my computer on plugging
in the the controller
um
let's see if this works or not
oh here you go here's controller wow
okay so it changes it to
okay i gotta remap my keys which
okay here's the inventory it would be a
lot harder to um
wow this is pretty good actually it's
kind of fast
uh-oh it's very possible
that my son broke my r1 key
give me one second y'all i'm gonna
switch controllers
so apologies um my r1 key on that
controller was stuck in dead so we're
going to try swapping controllers and
hopefully it
recognizes it there you go maybe yep
let's do one two three four
so here you go dude it's fast like
surprisingly fast um okay so wow
the potions are kind of weird though
it's left it's left right down
for that um and i gotta figure out how
to map my keys so bear with me because i
haven't played
on controller but i know you guys wanted
to see that so
oh we can bind a skill okay so let's
find that too
okay we bound that to x and we can bind
this to
let's say y and okay that's
all right cool um let's try it i'm going
to try to remember my buttons here
i also don't know my my hotkey but this
tree is
one of a kind uh
where is which ones do i have to go into
here to use my scroll
nope that wasn't it um
oh i have to hold to use it i had to
hold a to use my town portal
okay
it's not in town okay
oh there
so now we go back to stony field
so if you guys get sick of me playing on
controller just tell me i just know that
there was a request
you know what's interesting too the the
um
enemies the enemy
do you guys see the uh little thing over
the enemy's head that the name plates
are different
did i not wait do i saw the scroll
that's super weird talking to a car i
should have
should have triggered the quest no
okay it did so i was just pressing the
wrong
we're just guessing even though i know
you can look up the solution
oh it might have been trying to swing
which is kind of
that's a little annoying it looks good
on controller too yeah it's surprising
i talked to a car already
the land here is dead and lifeless
dude all tristram looks so good uh but
yeah if you guys
the the running is kind of weird when
you when you collide on something it
kind of sticks a little bit which is
interesting but i guess it makes sense
because you're running into an object
i do kind of like the nameplates though
like so i guess this is
trying to simulate what it might be if
you're playing on consoles so i'm
guessing
those name plates which don't show up on
um
pc at all
would be that way on oh god he amped me
the potion thing is kind of weird though
i don't know how i feel about that
it's like having to remember that it's
like up and down and all that stuff
like it's not very instinctive right now
but it's okay because in d3 you only had
one pot
that was on cooldown so now you can kind
of spam pots right so
definitely we'll take getting some used
to
but you know it it's pretty good
i have to say
yeah just remember this is alpha still
so you know
still work in progress but it gives you
kind of a taste of what it's going to
look like right on pc
or sorry on a console because i imagine
you know same thing maybe it looks
slightly
different graphically just based on the
console that you're on but
[Music]
that's a little trickier though probably
to uh pick up what
exactly what you want we want words leg
so
um this
this this would take some time though
the uh the inventory is gonna
it it's definitely workable the
inventory it's just gonna take getting
used to
um
yeah i to be honest with you i haven't
played path of exile outside of pc so i
don't know how their
control scheme is but
[Music]
like holding down feels weird but i
guess it makes sense it makes sense um
it's i believe it's like playstation
xbox pc
and switch if i'm not mistaken
um
oh wow you have to actually okay so it
treats it like if you had a mouse and
whatever
you actually have to move it over to
sell it um
and then toggle run is l3 okay yeah i
see that now
we saved deckard which is good you can
start the id for us
uh maybe we'll go shop in a second
r3d okay wow our three
okay that's going to be something to
remember to do
um but yeah tell me if you guys want to
keep watching it in uh
controller mode or if you guys just
prefer pc i i'm down to play either way
to be honest with you kind of cool to
see it in um
this way uh inventory management's gonna
take a little bit longer though so sorry
good day hey charcy
oh we could have checked um a car to see
if she had any better
like weapons i guess
yes i'll take the skull cap over the uh
yes yep we got a two socket yep
take that too save this
save this for later or whatever we want
is there any hit recovery belt nope
nothing there no boots
telekinesis mode please uh yeah i don't
have that sorry
any idea when this is going to launch no
sorry wilson no
um no idea yet in terms of
oh no i did not get the dark wood
oh that's a bummer we gotta walk back
that's on me
i got too excited with the uh
with the whole playing on controller
that i kind of forgot about the uh
forgot to leave a tp open at um
darkwood that was a mistake
so apologies for that i also think i
leveled and haven't used skill points
but
so yeah so there's definitely some
there's going to be some inefficiencies
um control the mouse compared to uh
mouse keyboard but that's if you're
trying to like
you know speed run or i don't know just
be super optimal wait am i not just oh
no
so like for me to use
me to do that so like
like that's a little bit annoying
oh yeah d1 on ps1 that's crazy it's been
so long
try my first air pg and then like the
first time i ever learned to like
dupe that was so fun do do books and
spells and
king sort of haste and godly plate of
whale
and apocalypse staff of or staff of
apocalypse is that what it was
i think the staff apocalypse
you need more blood and gore bale runs
yeah so they're doing something
efficient more efficient on that front
too i think they said like
where if you somehow killed bale
and this is from the round table i think
they said if you somehow killed bale on
normal on accident or someone killed
bale in your run
you could actually um still join normal
bail runs without
like being pushed to nightmare like you
would in the in the past
which is like you know obviously a huge
deal
um because you know you'd want to farm a
level bail
before you swap to nightmare
can i not run and do potion at the same
time
don't worry about apologizing making
mistakes make mistakes
thanks i appreciate it it kind of works
um
that was from okj i appreciate that
how are you guys digging the um the
console
type uh i guess semi ui
and the control schemes and all that
stuff you guys you guys a fan
are you guys going to play mostly mouse
keyboard what do you got
what are y'all thinking
this is resurrected uh i can oh i
actually don't know what the button is
to go
uh og on
is it this no that's map
um here i just do on my keyboard
oh wow okay cool so there's still
keyboard functionality without totally
just taking over the keyboard
so even though i did keyboard there it
recognized that i was still
on my controller so that's cool
this is what it looked like back in the
day and if you wanted to do that
uh you can seamlessly kind of do that
while you're playing
which is cool
i'm gonna have to fix my other
controller later i was trying to press
r1 for like the longest time not that i
guess it matters but i realized that it
was
it got it got jammed up
and we gotta go to inventory
i mean luckily the the the scroll there
um for the little circle
indicator that you saw it's pretty fast
so that that's nice
but you still do have to kind of like
drag and drop um either for
you know equipment that you're wearing
or selling i would definitely play on
ps4 with controller yes sick
anyone play hellfire on pc yeah anyone
play um
hell gate london remember that game
can you keep the ui scheme while playing
mouse keyboard i'm not sure i'd have to
take a look at the
the settings but we can definitely check
it is weird though because it basically
auto
kind of changed to this mode once i went
pc i mean uh controller
so
you know what i should do oh sorry let
me switch back to this and let me do one
more thing
sorry all right uh oh
okay cool oh you know what it was the
game okay that's my fault i clicked
into it with my mouse and the game was
uh trying to switch over to the to the
mouse
um sorry i i turned on uh
a local record of this just because i
think it's pretty cool to see the
different ui
and we don't have any of that up so
so uh yeah oh darn you know what else i
need to do i need to get chat back
can i not reach them so we will try to
test the uh
keeping this kind of ui layout in this
in a little bit
maybe after we kill countess let's go
find the let's try to get to uh
the next area and kill the countess and
then we'll uh
what is uh
swap
oh is r3 my bad
oh okay okay i need to map those keys to
throw
oh boy
[Music]
i need to get chat back though
[Music]
sorry like on my other window i um
minimized it to move some other stuff
around
but we're trying to find the tower and
then i'll uh i can't care
i'll do that
i think also what i need to do
but i will say yeah controller feels
good um definitely more than playable
as we slaughter all these carvers
all right so to mow island to mow
highland
is uh right there so all right
hoping to find the
countess shortly we could do countess
runs if people want that i don't know
the farm farm ruins
[Music]
probably have some uh
items to use
what i need to figure out it may be chad
if you see it when next time i run out
of stamina's if it
auto turns off your run i would imagine
so
if you run out of stamina meaning you'd
have to
toggle it back on every time i guess
[Music]
a stench of poison i think i said this
earlier but
great suggestion whoever asked to see uh
the
i am overburdened the uh
i have five stat points um
uh oh uh oh because i my son dropped
something
at least it wasn't the controller again
oh this is not good
yep and we died we died because we got
amped and i didn't see it that is
completely my fault of course it would
be the barb that dies who you would
think is the sturdiest
uh you can remember remind me that
that's rip counter one i think the
fastest way to get out of this would be
to save and exit
no i don't want the survey
dang it
so what happens when you toggle in
between uh
okay so go back in
go back in and we'll get chat back
there's my dead body
pick my dead body up awesome
get back to the black marsh the map back
open
well there's always a first right
[Music]
to be honest i blame the controller
i wish i could actually that was just my
fault i
got uh trapped and then i um
and i got cursed which is just asking
for trouble right
i mean this this is controller right
zuka i mean this is pretty much what you
you can kind of come to expect i think
when you play
um upcoming looks like you have
what up to that was weird up to five
abilities
or six sorry six abilities that you
could slot in
and then i'm not sure what it looks like
to try to get more
all right this is a boss pack
[Music]
there is definitely more of a blood
splatter than um
before
yes you're a i'm alive now
so anytime you see well it doesn't stay
there but you can see at the very top
whenever there's minion uh under the
name
it those enemies give you more
experience
and i think the reason why people ran
the uh tower here is because
there were so many champion packs in it
[Music]
so they are equipped to throw
but i can't throw them so
um that's the one thing i'm not sure of
i can't because i don't know how to map
the throw
for the for the gas huh
and like i said the gas is pretty good
because you can
one shot that guy all right i am
overburdened
yes yes yes i'm sorry
oh and then i also i wonder
what the buttons are to do the emotes
because all the d all you almost all
your keys are being used right so you
you don't have the like time to die
and all this stuff anymore
this is when the whole like
controller things a little bit more
sketch
normally i'd be just spamming my pots
right um
taking me a second to think about the
muscle memory
to
inventory management is no fun though
i'll tell you that right now with the
mask or a controller but
i mean it it's functional right and it
works so
does each spell have a specific button
yeah oh oops yes i met i met i can show
you guys that again but yes i'm
basically mapping them right so like
when you go into your
skill tree you can map the button so
if for example let's say i take i don't
know we'll take a leap right
do i want leap um
[Music]
i don't know if i want leap but uh i'm
not gonna take it but yeah you would
hold x right and then you would pick the
button you want so right now i have it
on x i could switch it to b
and then if i wanted to switch it back
like so you you do end up mapping it
the way you want it to be or the button
you want it to be on
i think there's usually a champ pack
down here but um
oh yeah you gotta hold it to use it
come on
stop whipping
your blood will boil
all right so we got a tur and a ralph
ralph's nice because of the fire damage
i think if we got a uh
l ruin we could make steel
or i can just kind of progress it's up
to you guys if you guys want me to do
um
you guys want me to farm or just keep
going
uh john i don't know how long
you've you've been away from gamespot
and that you know you
that take can be true but you realize
that he's back
with us as our sister company with giant
bomb and he's kind of talked about
jeff gertzman that is has talked about
kind of everything that's happened and
why he's back and why he came like you
know why he's okay
you know and all that stuff so you know
just wanted to point that out um because
i feel like it's kind of trolly and i
just want people to be informed that
that's a thing i talked to jeff i've
worked with jeff
it's a great guy oh
boy we need to put some stuff away
why does it bring up your whole
inventory not sure that's just how
that's just how the the i guess console
version of it would look like
or how it would be controlled via um
controller so
[Music]
i still don't know how to map my
throwables so maybe we just
dump them i'm just gonna
oops there's a faster way to drop that's
my bed it's x
use the shout uh i think i already used
my skill point so i can
can't do it later i think we need more
inventory space i don't think they're
gonna change
that but
i think i think controller in this case
works perfectly fine
i mean some of the stuff i was
mentioning are so subtle and not that
important
and my son wants to say hello
yeah hi bud
you want the controller you broke here
take that
so we're gonna make our way once i can
do this
to the uh outer cloister
we'll see if uh and ariel
gives us the business later
you glad to see the added batista yeah
fan favorite right
did i get any um chipped rubies because
that would be pretty good right now i
think
i don't think i did though right no i
think when i put away my gems i didn't
have it i guess i could have stuck a
railroad in one of these but
that seems
i always forget there's a way to tell
based off of the uh
location of the waypoint
on which way you need to go to to get to
the bears
you're still missing maybe i should go
more base mastery instead of double
swing
yep this was not the way
yeah the walking is better someone had
mentioned like there's a little bit of a
like a lean
that you can kind of see a little bit
i mean i can turn on um classic and show
it to you right
like and it's funny because it keeps the
ui which is great
so good good for them
all right we found the right way
hopefully the um what you call it
doesn't mess me up too the smith
oh this is why you need faster hit
recovery because holy crud
the sun lock is real
so next time we go back to town i'll see
if charcy's got anything
with the like boots or something or
gloves with hit recovery
because yeah getting stun locked like
that is not good from the archers
probably gonna get us killed to be
honest
oh we have skills to see that's the one
that's the one thing though
so used to be able to like you know you
can kind of like level on the fly
okay got some scary
the old doorway strat right no it's not
gonna work because they got shaman
oh this bench is owning me hold on
come here right that was a normal one
wolfhead could be good good money
it's kind of the stuff you want to pick
up you didn't know
could have abilities on it basically
even though there's no druid in this uh
current
oh the uh nope okay last time
when we found the smith he was near a
well
what's the benefit of keeping ui up
when you switch to classic uh there's no
benefit i just i don't know it's like a
thing right like i don't know i'm glad
they did it
there's not really a benefit it's more
just like i'm visually
uh cool that they kind of kept on point
but that's built in maybe that's just
like a thing that you assumed would
happen but
i don't know i think it's cool i guess
oh there's a smith
i bet you will
this is a slugfest batista is winning
i should have uh
oh this is the tough part i want that
preserved head thank you
all right yesterday on stream i forgot
the herat
the like mace thing but i will not
forget today
all right i should take i guess we just
go to charcy right
uh yeah let's just go to charcy because
um
hold to sort i wonder i wonder if
there's a way to bind the um
tp oh
deckard identify my items deckard yes
can you comment on how different the
feel is with controller versus
keyboard it feels more if i feel that
warren's considering the differences
between it enough to justify a sub genre
between the two
um like i said i like my opinion on that
is just that
you're you can be a little bit more
efficient on
pc keyboard mouse i mean um
in that you know you could level while
you're running
you can um
you know put your skill points in as
you're running
but i mean this is how it kind of was
for d3 too on like
console right i think that
it took up the whole menu too and i
think i remember multi
oh half freeze duration is pretty good
those gloves are so expensive though
oh this is pretty good what's on my belt
now
oh yeah we'll buy this
uh okay
game feel wise yeah i don't i don't
think you necessarily need a sub-genre
for it i think it's just going to be the
same as
every other like if you're going down to
like the elitist route or whatever
every other elitist argument about how
like you know
it's not going to be fair for you know
people that
play on controller versus keyboard and
mouse but i know that there's plenty of
people who are still very
good and can compete with keyboard mouse
players
i'm gonna buy the two socket and
i don't know i guess this one has more
value
so we'll sell that it's 4 000 gold
nice we just want these for the sockets
i don't have anything good
like i don't think i have any tripped
rubies right
you can take a look at what we what ship
gems we have yeah we don't really have
anything good
i think fire is the most damage right i
guess we could put the rao ruin in
i can't imagine playing with it well
matt have you played um d3 or
or uh on console or path of exile
because i
you know i for the longest time i
thought it wouldn't play that well but
then
it actually feels pretty good minus some
some minor little things but i think
those minor things for me
are just because i'm used to it like ah
this this i'm not so much of a fan of
right but
i feel like most of the other stuff's
not bad i can switch back by the way
um if you guys care
you don't care
and then there's like this is kind of
little annoying i guess
should probably be going all like um
vitality whatever it's fine
not doing anything crazy
a lot of uh
no lightning is so bad
lightning and the fact that uh these
these these uh
archers are just kids stunning the crap
out of me
it's not so good
i'm tired of these hair ads sorry
i hope this will have a great game and
getting like critters i
honestly don't know if they're gonna
like
i don't think they're adding any of that
but i know maybe someone in chat knows
better than me
but i don't think they're adding that i
think the longevity of this game was
like
trying to farm the really good stuff and
you have to imagine that like
it's gonna be way harder now with no
like botting right well like someone
will come up with a bot
stuff like pindlebot and all that stuff
but
um
i just like how hard is it gonna be to
get like a zod right
and to make some of the high end
high-end
uh
the high-end kind of ruined words right
oh god i guess sure these other boots
are terrible
all right
there's some quality of life stuff on
top of just the graphics though oh
finally an amulet
that's good um like this is kind of slow
too right having to hold down the button
to
oh gosh that's not very good but
you know we'll take it for now we don't
have anything else
this is a dead end
yeah you also realize as wilson
mentioned like with kids it becomes
harder to do the whole pc gaming thing
i think and easier to do kind of
gaming but when you reach that point in
your life you may or may not agree i
guess
i'm with you though wilson i am
especially like switch
because they might be taking up the tv
at that point you know there's just so
many factors
it's kind of kind of a whole other thing
so unless anything says any anything
about this i will probably
i'll try to fight in dariel
controller but i'm kind of nervous about
it
yeah oh that's a good point by zuka too
like really one of the things you chased
and the reason why you played was um to
play
for the latter and then being like first
to 99
and then also having access to some
ruined words you wouldn't have playing
single player
because they have already mentioned that
you can't load old
saves so you could i guess in theory you
could find like those god like
kind of builds or like preset builds
and play those but you know
you're not gonna you're not gonna it's
not gonna be the same i guess because
i don't know it feels better when you
you get a drop right like
i don't know
like i got a i got a uh what did i get
yesterday arctic sash
and that was cool right i was like oh we
got a green item um
and then and then i guess you just do a
bunch of forge runs because
you're trying to oops you got to try to
get like
good runes i don't need like i'm curious
how like the
the economy works cause
you know back in the day i just went to
trade chat three or
u.s west trade chat three and you know
you're like well trade x and x for shaco
like i'm curious how much of that's
gonna be
in the game but i i gotta imagine it's
gonna be there
it'll be
but yeah it used to like stare at the uh
auction chat or whatever like it was the
stock market
i really hope d4 delivers d3 was a huge
letdown
um i i feel like d3 at the beginning at
the start got a bad rap because i think
a lot of
one it was very hard right um once you
got to like late game and then two
there was the auction house right which
kind of soured people's experience
i understand kind of why they did it i
actually didn't mind
the auction house personally because i
was one of those people
you know trying to farm and then you
know it was cool to be able to finally
sell stuff that you found that was like
really good and you're like cool i made
money
that i would like you know put back to
my wow subscription
or whatever right um but i think that
all kind of made it sour
but i think reaper of the souls really
did a lot of good for that game
uh especially once they had gave you the
ability to kind of skip the story
go full adventure mode and i almost feel
like the
the console players got like the best
version right of that game
and i was happy to play that game oh
this is not
this looks like a scary room okay
we are cursed that's not good and those
guys are scary
i think we're just going to avoid except
i can't avoid
because now we have a room full of this
stuff
and we're at a dead end
well if we're gonna get away from that
um cursed monster we might be okay
like see my problem right now right is i
can't
normally i would go potentially into my
inventory right to
like move more pots in but i couldn't do
that so
oops
sure we'll just keep that for now um
but yeah back to my d3 point i think d3
start was not that good
i think reaper of souls made that game a
lot better i think the seasons were
pretty
good they they started introducing
different
things you know at some point there was
ancient um
items primordial new sets sets that did
different things granted i'm still kind
of on the fence about sets in general
just because
it always felt like you were playing one
kind of cookie cutter build for each
class
to you know min max the greater rift but
i think that they had a better
end game right there with greater rifts
i don't know how many of you folks are
playing
outriders but the expeditions that are
at the end
of this is weird
am i crazy oh sorry
um the expeditions that are at
like kind of like the end game of um
of outriders is basically a greater rift
right it's got
time on it uh the faster you do it the
more loot you get
and it's kind of just one long kind of
arena right
getting to the end killing bosses
killing
enemies and i just feel like there's a
lot of good there right
so i don't know i but i i
like d3 a lot i've probably poured
thousands of maybe thousands
a lot more but definitely put in over a
thousand hours into that game
um just between console and pc
you know i the reason why i liked having
it on switch and why
i'm going to really enjoy having
something like d2 on switch is because
you can bring that on the plane you know
and maybe that's
maybe to someone's point it's like yeah
there can't be an online only in that
case right at least for a single player
um and dude i could i could play d2
on the airplane the whole time get it
you know get some free snacks from the
and a drink you know and just or
when you're waiting for a plane or i
don't know man the switch has just been
a great
place and it's cool to have something
like diablo
something i really enjoy playing on
like that platform sure there's going to
always be that thing about
like you know pcs where it started and
you're still going to want to play on pc
don't discount the power of the switch
a different place to play that's uh
portable i guess
3ds forever yeah they're not doing too
much on there anymore
if you think d3 was designed as a
console you're an ignorance
um matthew let's think about that for a
second though right
and and you can this is this is my take
and you can flame me hate me for it
right
but if you think about it right if you
think about
how many skills they they kind of gave
you as
a like a prerequisite of like how many
you could actually have
on your skill tree at any time if you
look at it it maps
like one to one console right like here
for example you only have six
abilities so what happens if you have
more than six abilities that you want to
do i don't know i
i don't know where the extra buttons
come from and so the reason why i bring
that up
is because um
all the buttons map out one to one right
there's you have
six abilities i i believe not counting
like
you know potions and stuff like that but
your abilities pretty much
were like one-to-one to your controller
so
i want to believe that they didn't
totally have that in their mind to begin
with but like
it kind of has too many coincidences
there or
that coincidence is very big for me um
which is why i always thought like oh i
guess it makes sense that they're gonna
eventually go to
the console because they're forcing you
to use
x amount of buttons which like is like
the exact thing for controller and maybe
i'm just
speculating and looking into it too much
but that's
kind of my take on it also it's super
weird like i never have to repair
or something like repair should be down
here right
uh whoops
i don't know if i'll get it for ps4 or
switch yeah i don't that's a tough one
like i said i'm i'm throwing the money
at them i'm gonna probably buy pc
and uh switch the one good thing is
there's cross save i don't think there's
cross
play though or at least they have not
talked about that
wow nice we sell that
the dodge roll was nice too as eternal
uh cmo brings up that on console
you did have that cons that that little
roll
and um wow this maze has so many
abilities on it let me see if any of
it's good
[Music]
uh like it's it's got to be better than
the one that's got nothing in it right
like
yeah we just and we're based anyways so
i'll just keep that for now
so we have a belt with hip recovery
gloves would be pretty good
there's those half freeze duration
gloves we're just staring at us we might
need to
you know what we're just gonna buy them
in case like i don't know seems like a
pretty good thing to have considering
how bad bloodraven was owning me earlier
we'll just take it
probably should have sold this ring
this is the one kind of annoying thing
though i will say is the inventory
wait you can just drop into the
inventory with x
that's what's faster probably mouse and
drag is probably faster right
33 is not a real diablo game come on it
is
it's just not the one you wanted i i had
to come to terms
with that too but it oh i don't know why
about that many antidotes
we are gonna fight andy though soon so
is there a way to put this into
i don't know i guess there's not a
faster way to fill the belt huh
uh then we gotta reorganize wait hold
the sword
hold okay so if you hold r3 it auto
swords but i don't know how i feel about
how that looks but whatever i i don't
think there's an auto sort for um
cons uh pc so that's that's another
interesting
kind of like semi-quality of life
thing that i guess you get with a
controller instead of keyboard mouse
poe 2 is coming i don't think they
announced a release date for that either
right or did they
i did i don't think i watched the end of
the trailer i just kind of watched some
of the gameplay
um a nice little walk through by chris
wilson
uh if you guys just know about uh path
of exile
crystal
for that half freeze duration we bought
those gloves for a reason
is that really like half i don't know
i don't buy it
and i'm guessing it doesn't pause right
hope that's not what i wanted
wow that's kind of okay
you didn't invest into some shout outs
my man okay let's do some shout outs
for the chat i'll do some shout outs
okay uh
oh it does not pause on the inventory
everything was
when did we get the good one though
right battlecry no
where's the good shot where's the one
that improves my oh there you go
defense all right fine here we'll get a
shout
uh and then i'll bind this to be
oh yeah oh that animation though huh
do i still have a skill point oh sorry
nope nope nope uh
maybe b is a bad button b's kind of like
my cancel button on controller so that's
gonna throw me off quite a bit i think
inventory management stop it
yeah and d4 feels far right i think it's
like 22 right
i think
i'm not mistaken just because you know
obviously the pandemic has slowed down
production like everything right there's
so many games that have been delayed
this year
either into like next year
i can't carry anymore targe wouldn't be
a bad thing to pick up but
wait what
don't love that why do they make it full
screen i'm not sure to be honest
maybe it just needs to do that for the
controller to
do what it needs to um
i don't have an answer for you in terms
of why it doesn't although it doesn't
correct me if i'm wrong here but i think
on
i want to say when you play on d3 on
um i can't carry anymore
d3 on
like console doesn't it also do that
darn we got to keep that
i'm pretty sure it does that too right
or it takes over the whole menu
and it even like pauses you i think to
some degree you're just stuck there
right
uh so fun fact and i know this is not
gonna um
not gonna be a a chat favorite here
and i'm gonna say oh
i guess it's a little harder i did not
play immortals
okay but what i will say
is the gameplay that i saw of it from
one of our editors michael hyam who's
also checking out diablo
uh resurrected so you should check out
his article on gamespot.com if you have
it
um what i saw of it and of the gameplay
i cut out
you know what i'd probably i'd probably
play it on mobile too
it's one of those things where you
probably um
like it's sneaky it's sneaky
sneaky fun and maybe you just don't tell
anyone
that you're playing it on mobile if
you're worried about that at all
hope chip skull we'll take it in case
but i i would play it i i i'll be i'll
admit it to you guys and y'all i would
play it
i would honestly play diablo immortals
on my phone no joke
i know that's not gonna be a popular
opinion here
but surprisingly
i would do it it looks fun and it looks
like it works
it looks like it would work on that
platform um
i am overburdened i probably just i
can't carry it anymore
i just got a lot of people upset by
saying that but hey
i'm just trying to be real
it looks like a game i would play on my
phone
just like i was alluding to why i play
on switch and all that stuff if i was on
the bart which is our trend well we're
not going to bart anytime soon with the
pandemic but if i was on bart which is
our kind of like
underground rail system and i'm going
back and forth between work
i'm not gonna lie to you i'd probably uh
you know
play that uh in between not gonna lie to
you if i was on the john
and you know i needed to play a game
that would probably be a pretty good
game to play on the
on the john just on the on the loo
maybe that was tmi i don't know
apologies it was
forgive me
can i use my saved game from 2005.
apparently yes
i would have to imagine that's on pc
though
and i well you know what if there's
cross save maybe if you have two
and this is up to you if you want to do
it if you had it on like pc
and let's say switch or something like
that because of the crosstalk i would
imagine
you could then load it up to play on
your
uh you could load up your save to play
on the other platform
all right wait
how is that a thing oh
whoops okay hold on hold on no now this
makes sense
i mapped it to a i need to map
here's a question how do i map auto
attack now that i don't have it
huh
is there not a way for me to
do hockeys
or oh here you go general skills derp oh
there's the throw too okay
okay okay and there's town portals lt
plus a
okay it's all coming together now so if
you want quicktime portal lt plus a
if i want to throw
put that in right trigger so like that's
okay okay so you have some more
functionalities there
so it looks like for the more skills
right
what it's doing is combining two buttons
right to make it happen
so if you need more skills that's how
they're going to do it right they're
going to combine it with the trigger
oh we need to uh we just put a town
portal on top that's fine
we're about to fight andy put it in chat
if you think i'm going to die
you think i'm going to live i want to
know yesterday everyone in chat was
telling me i was going to die
so you know
that little faith it was understandable
chad loves to see when the streamer dies
right
mobile gaming activist here ah
i'm just saying i personally would play
i'm not
i'm not saying it's for everyone but
i don't know even cod mobile kind of
worked right to some degree
sorry you're going to die get some
antidotes i have some antidotes
now the way i have it mapped right now
is probably not the greatest so i guess
we can put it on
the belt because trying to get into this
menu
while fighting her is probably going to
be impossible
um i think we have more stat allocations
let's just beef up our vitality
we're gonna check out our skills here
eight percent attack rating five percent
more damage
it's five percent attack rating so i
guess mace is better
sure whatever it's fine all right good
luck to us
uh chat me try to clear out some of this
stuff first actually
deal with some less trash
oh okay sorry i was gonna announce my
present
i mean just look at how good this area
looks right
we're face tanking it
it's a bad idea
i did not mean to go and
stop hitting candy
you know what's interesting though they
automatically put your regions in which
is nice
so like when you saw me run out of uh
the antidotes
it like basically added
the rejuves in for me without me loading
it so it's almost like preloading my
belt back up it looks like i am
overburdened
uh we'll take the ring mail right so we
should check that in a second
oh actually huh
so i didn't have any of those pots right
except for my mana pot in there but it
was giving me the option to use the
potions that were in my inventory
which kind of seems cheap to be honest
with you
um because you saw like for sure 100
i know that for a fact that once i
stopped using the antidotes
it definitely gave me the regions um
right into my
into my belt
nope uh
that that's a little bit frustrating
okay no chipped emerald
is there a better way to do this that
i'm not i can't carry anymore
well i couldn't carry any more that's
fine um
wasn't there something else i am
overburdened
all right oh did you guys want to see
the difference or have you guys seen it
already
um here hold on so like i was showing
so there's dead andy right i can't carry
anymore oh we need that
because why not uh sorry sorry sorry
uh so there's dead andy we can focus in
on that
kind of awkward a little bit um look
can you even see and ariel there
is she dead uh is that her body i can't
really tell
right can you can you tell
is that is that in dario but then if
you're like
oh but there she is
surprise um
graphics are definitely much better
right
and then we can oh we can't emote
is my num lock off oh we can't emote
that's that's sad times that's okay
uh no idea wiggly i'd have to imagine
this comes out this year right because
we're in alpha already so
and then it really comes down to like
when we get
um announcement for d4 who knows though
right
oh my lord i just wanted to talk to
deckard
deckard get away from the portals
that's the one thing that might be a
deal breaker for uh
a controller at least on pc i probably
would never play a controller on a pc
though um
we kept that because we wanted to
definitely selling that
i mean we'll probably just use that for
now until we
find something worth
40 decks to throw that happening
all right we're gonna go to loot colaine
here in a second
act two
there is here
[Music]
deposit my money so i don't lose it
[Music]
and then we'll be uh on our way to act
two uh we could technically watch the
cut scene
but you know oops hold on
forget if there's any and i don't think
there is rewards right
actual merc is like really strong uh we
found that out on chain chat yesterday
he he basically saved me
do you guys want to watch the old d2 um
cut scene probably not right
i'm going to skip what
oh right it does this thing where it
like plays the
travel east it's okay
it plays like the uh greetings on i am
jiren
just like town music underneath the
cinematic problem just because it's not
fully optimized yet
again it is an alpha y'all so
you don't have to trust me if you don't
i know
let's see what does she have
yeah two socket warning star i guess
we'll buy because there's just more
damage right
even the armors like looks better right
it looks different
i think durio's just gonna straight murk
me though it's not my belt
hit recovery huh that's unfortunate
i think we got to get the belt though um
because this belt gives us access to uh
three
three rows of pots so yeah we definitely
want the belt
all right we are going to go kill
radiments
come on ryan they did not uh
i bet you one i mean sure i i can't
dispute that the uh 100
percent can't dispute that uh
immortals could be a cash grab but it
also is
like you gotta imagine it's i'm not
trying to defend them right i'm just
trying to think logically why they do it
like
there's probably like uh they see asia
as a very strong market for mobile games
and that's why
i have to imagine immortals makes a lot
more sense there than like
hearing it like you know and that's
probably
kind of what's going on do we want might
or a defensive aura
you know what we had hazard yesterday
and he was really good to us so we're
gonna hire him
um if we have some spare cash we might
just get him some some gear
oh you know what's also interesting okay
there's mercenary right
there this is some nice ui um
quality of life stuff here
but yeah i don't do i have anything not
really huh
i guess
sure
damn that's kind of expensive
uh is this cheaper all right
okay
all right just so that our mercenary is
a bit
stronger i'll put that together i don't
think i could make this
better but i don't know so okay cool
uh we're gonna do a radiment and then
probably
i don't i probably unfortunately don't
have much more time
too much after that i'm gonna go back to
mouse and keyboard it's gonna like
slag for a second
and then we go oh this is gonna be
interesting i gotta remap this
not here
so we go this way because usually the
stairs
uh okay i'm not gonna lie i fee it feels
better
but it was still very playable
i'm just used to playing diablo this way
personally
and i bet you the other reason why they
saw so much success or like why they
even thought about doing diablo
on um mobile is maybe they saw the
success of hearthstone
and how just how big hearthstone was for
them
that um you know ultimately you're not
wrong that
you know it's it's definitely going to
be a it's a money play but i don't think
that like
the quality of their games has gone down
because they decided to make a move
i'm really enjoying this game i'm going
to play d4
you know part of me hopes that like
d4 if you know because i would i don't
know what path of exile is gonna come
out but like let's say
they're both 2022 for some reason um
whatever it is i just hope that they're
far enough apart from each other that
like
i get to enjoy
that's my hope at least
i don't know what's hitting me
no i just gave him a pot
clearly buying all that arbor for him
but yeah i want to play both and i'm
just hoping they don't come out at the
same time
i'm so hyped for this game says bap yup
i'm with you
i'm just like i said really fortunate to
be able to play
get get access to the alpha it's been a
blast
been happy to you know be able to stream
and just
chat with other diablo fans
i don't know it's been a good time
definitely a great way to get to friday
here
i'm sorry that i have to cut
put it a little short uh
but you know we at least got through act
one
uh and we're gonna check out you know
part of acts
two here i'm gonna try to kill radomin
and that'll be kind of how we
and you know for context what it used to
look
this is what my like used to look like
i had a lot of fun
playing with it to know if it's good or
bad
normally i'd pick up that sacred glow
but because we're on a little bit of a
time crunch
probably press forward here and try to
find it
try to get us a skill point
it also kind of
takes a little bit of adjusting getting
used to back uh the ui
change the slight ui change because like
stamina here is on the
left where stamina was on the right
because i had to put all the
hotkeys maps um across kind of the
bottom bar
not the biggest thing in the world still
i really like that zoom in feature yeah
it's wrong but
this one it definitely is helps you
appreciate what they're able to do
in this this game right it doesn't it
doesn't do the old game any justice but
but it's also good to just so that you
can for context see the difference right
uh this is where i would give that ring
mail to hazari
i guess we should have just blew the
railroad on the one of the stones
for the morning star i guess it doesn't
matter
carries forward progression-wise
man piss of the heaven basically right
pretty cool animation there oh we got it
through
okeydoke
yeah alpha is the only first first two
accent oh
i would stream more but um it's no time
today so sorry
apologies see it was weird i didn't have
to
repair at all
okay well on that note
picket mode on i'd love to pick it back
for those who know what pick it is
but uh on that note really appreciate
everyone kind of swinging by
hanging out chatting talking about
either their
love or disdain for certain diablos but
i really had fun
i hope you guys have a great weekend uh
there's more diablo stuff on gamespot
youtube gamespot.com if you guys want to
check it out
and of course you know whenever the next
alpha beta comes
i'm sure we'll hop into that one i think
there's multiplayer on that one maybe we
can get pvp going on if multiplayer is
happening but
we'll have to see don't want to speak
too soon because i don't know what's in
that alpha or beta
but uh until next time have yourselves a
great day
have yourselves a great weekend
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you